radical repugnant Republican
congresswoman Lauren bobert bizarrely
was praying in the capital rotunda now
as many of you know I am not a Christian
so I've wondered for a long time when
people say they were pleading the blood
of Jesus what the hell does that mean
I'm wondering is this video
Lauren bobert pleading the blood of
Jesus you tell me what's going on here
take a look
it comes to you
more presence God we thank you so much
for your goodness it is your goodness
that leads men to repentance that causes
men to change their mind about you God
be a different side of your Holiness
yeah God we love you because you first
loved us Jesus thank you for your
Redemptive work it was complete it was
full there was nothing missing there was
nothing lacking there's nothing that you
left out Jesus
price for each and every one of us he
went to hell in our place
rose again Victorious and when you were
seated at the right hand of the father
on high you did not leave us alone how
is this not mental illness
[Music]
all right I think you get the idea
nothing makes me respect religious
people less than when they orchestrate
conspicuous public prayers for publicity
genuinely and by the way listen I don't
care what Matthew says but in Matthew 6
6 it does say when you pray go into your
room close the door and pray to your
father who is unseen
then your father who sees what is done
in secret will reward you not that I
care what is in Matthew 6 6 but if
Lauren bobert claims to shouldn't she be
following that dictate and not
orchestrating this pathetic public stunt
anyway is that pleading the blood of
Jesus maybe somebody can tell me what it
is